all right do you want to do the intro
hello
it's man and woman caring bang i don't
know you do it i don't know no that was
good keep keep it up i'm going to put
that in you know oh my god this is jake
and nadia of the man carrying thing
universe the mct you as some people are
calling it that's people are calling it
that let me get my book real quick while
he's not here
i should probably talk about how
never reads actually he just wikipedia
is everything he's never read a book in
his life whatever on my
uh birthday we went to the last
bookstore in downtown la and we're going
to talk a little bit about the books we
grabbed
and what we're going to
be reading
what do you sound out of breath because
i moved like five feet and that's kind
of where i'm at these days do you want
to go first i'm reading the mains so i
read the silent patient
um and i literally read it in one day
however it's been a slower read for me
i'm only on chapter
four it's not as good
it's good so far but it's just not as
like
i'm gonna eat it up oh wow it's not
yeah as some of you may know i've been
reading gap cycle by stephen r donaldson
excellent writer and i read the first
two book in the series and at the last
book store they happen to have the first
three books in paperback which i don't
have the real story forbidden knowledge
which i read recently very good
surprisingly good and this is the next
one in the series which has the most
badass title for any science fiction
book a dark and hungry god arises oh
that's like me in breakfast time yeah it
is except goddess okay
i bought the secret wife and it seemed
really interesting to me because it
starts in russia in a brink of collapse
they discover the great grandfather's
secret wife in a remote cabin men
that's all you're going to say
you're just going to say men and leave
it all right all right so i guess while
she reads i'm going to what he kept her
a secret i think this is an original
printing of the second book in the
chronicles of thomas covenant series by
stephen r donaldson same author i
haven't read the first one lord false
bane but i stay had the second one there
and i was like i had to grab that i just
couldn't resist well this is not what i
got at the last book store this time but
i got it a while ago i think i got this
um it's called bunny i started reading
it too it's good a scholarship student
who prefers a company for dark
imagination to that of most people yeah
he jumps between books to books it's so
annoying no one does that i do it next
up out of sight elmore leonard came out
in the 90s it was turned into a movie i
believe george clooney you know for a
guy who wants to be out of sight he
loves being in sight see what i did
there it's short i love elmore leonard
my amazing mother-in-law got me
the next books in the wheel of time
series dragon reborn which i'll be
reading very soon and the shadow rising
these are actually a little nicer than
the great hunt book that i have because
they have the
map painted on the inside i love the old
illustrated covers i hope they never
change it are you tired
did this take the energy out of you yeah
recording one video
no recording a video with you oh thank
you for watching it's been a pleasure
yeah thank you is that how you sign off
how do you sign off
okay ready one two three bye
i might that hurt my soul